we are thrilled to be back to present
the Oscars for best supporting actor and
supporting actress
besides sharing groundbreaking wins last
year we also share a love of
collaborating with others to connect
with an audience
we are both so pleased and encouraged
that the movies and the people who make
them are becoming more inclusive and
more of a reflection of the audiences
that are inspired by them
in many earliest opportunities my roles
were voiced by other actors off stage
tonight it doesn't matter where the
sound comes from
this is me signing
and I am delighted to honor these
artists
though the characters they played are
not considered leads their contributions
to a film and the importance of their
roles are pivotal
here are the nominees for performance by
an actor in a supporting role
Brendan Gleason the Banshees of inner
sharing
Brian Tyree Henry Causeway
Judd Hirsch disablements
Barry Keogan the Banshees of initial
everything everywhere all at once
and the Oscar goes to
okay
[Applause]
debut in Indiana Jones and the Temple of
Doom and cleaned data in The Goonies he
holds a film decree from the USC School
of cinematic arts and has worked as a
stunt coordinator and assistant director
thank you
thank you ah
my mom is 84 years old
and she's at home watching Mom I just
want an Oscar
my journey started on a boat I spent a
year in a refugee camp
and somehow
I ended up here on Hollywood's biggest
stage
they say stories like this only happen
in the movies I cannot believe it's
happening to me this this is the
American dream
thank you so much thank you so much to
the academy for this honor of a lifetime
uh thank you to my mom for the
sacrifices she made to get me here
to my little brother
David who calls me every day just to
remind me to take good care of myself I
love you brother uh
thank you to Kendall for all your
support and everything you've done uh
thank you to a24 Dr Daniels Jonathan
Jamie Michelle and my Goonies brother
for life Jeff Cohen
I owe everything to the love of my life
my wife Echo who
two months after month
year after year for 20 years told me
that one day
one day my time will come
dreams are something you have to believe
in I almost gave up on mine to all of
you out there please keep your dreams
alive
thank you thank you so much for
welcoming me back I love you thank you
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]